normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
The Daily Mail woke Disney admits
misalignment between its movies and what
viewers want is harming its bottom line
after Progressive Snow White reboot was
pushed back for huge overhaul I just I
love the uh Financial legal academic way
of saying get woke go broke yeah exactly
we're
misaligned okay we have we have a phrase
for that here the here's the gist of it
Disney has warned its investors that the
company's products and political views
may not align with what viewers want and
risk harming its bottom line in a public
Financial filing for the fiscal quarter
ending in September the corporation
acknowledged the risks in it is taking
relating to misalignment with public and
consumer tastes and preferences for
entertainment that's amazing Disney has
struggled as of late to successfully
pitch its costly films to audiences
losing a reported $1 billion on its last
four High high profile releases and uh I
don't know if I actually have uh yes I
do have it pulled up of course Disney's
wish over Thanksgiving weekend was
another major box office bomb and I
think everybody knows that movie is
basically communist right is that is
that the general idea are are you
familiar with it Jeremy y basically if
there really was a God and if he was any
good he'd give us all everything we want
yeah but only in this movie it's a white
man who has the power to Grant
everything you want and refuses and God
white dude he's a white dude all right
yeah it's a documentary that's what it
is a documentary yeah so uh the the the
the big news here is they pushed back
Snow White which which shows not only
are they admitting to their
investors what we are doing is failing
they're taking corrective measures well
obviously the entire sort of Team
reality right marshaled a lot of
strength against well first with Bud
Light which I think is the greatest
boycott that we've ever seen uh in the
history of the right I mean we've never
been very good at that sort of taking
economic action punitive economic action
against anyone and after Dylan mulany
they you know they laid the Bud Light
low but now with Disney you saw the
entire right wi really come out against
them and and Dy wire you I'm proud to
say we took direct action and on the
100th anniversary of Disney back on
October 16th we announced the launch of
our kids platform bent key which is of
all the things we've ever built it's the
thing I'm I'm the most proud of we've
we've got 18 series on there four them
original two of those chip Chilla our
first animated series and a wonderful
day with Mabel mlay I think are both
genuinely wonderful shows I'm very proud
to have uh played a role in bringing
them to life but we also announced that
we were going to make our own liveaction
adaptation of the Grim's fairy tale Snow
White and we were doing that in
particular because Rachel Zigler had
been the the Disney's new Snow White had
been so outspokenly
against Snow White the the film that
made Disney uh into the powerhouse that
it is the 1937 animated film and she
said things like you know we're not
going to make a movie like that that
movie had all kinds of problems you know
it had we're not going to make a movie
where the where the prince saves the
princess or any of this stuff what's
beautiful about that well what's awful
about it obviously is that she's saying
that the actual company for whom she
works a company with the most brand
loyalty of any company maybe in all of
history is somehow poorly founded
somehow had bad values and she's she's
far far better of a person than Walt
Disney was but what's beautiful now is
if you look at what Disney's going to do
with the film you know you said it
almost a you know less than two weeks
later they they completely change course
on their adaptation they are now going
to make a more faithful adaptation and
Rachel Zigler has to actually be in the
movie that she hates I I'm I'm just
imagining this this this when when
you're talking about this you're making
the Snow White I'm imagining that you're
driving this little buggy Behind These
semis that are gold is pouring off the
back and you're just picking it up and
you're like well whatever I might as
well take this oh they threw that out
I'll take this one too if they want to
abandon their most valuable IP and the
things that made them valuable I see in
in so many ways with uh uh like Jeremy's
razors for instance and Jeremy's
chocolate you're like well if you don't
want it I guess I'll take it yeah and
now here here's the daily wire ex
exploding in in in popularity because
they're just giving away this this value
abandoning I mean I'm just a lowly I'm
just a lowly shampoo Mogul uh but I came
by it onon it you know they if they
don't want the business to your point
we're going to make the business and and
someone asked me you know what what will
you do if Disney manages the course
correct here first of all I don't think
they can I don't think that Disney I
think they know that something is a Miss
I don't think that they can identify the
difference between the parts of their
views that are so radical that the
public is rejecting them and the parts
of their views that aren't because they
live in a bubble within a bubble within
a bubble within a bubble people who've
worked for Disney uh have have told us
you know Disney has basically fired
everyone over the last five to seven
years who didn't tow that party line
there's no one left over there who would
know how to know how to do this if if
they were paid to but if they do manage
to course correct and if it cost me my
business I'll be like Elliot NES at the
end of uh The Untouchables I'll go have
a drink like what we won we won there it
would be far better for our culture it'
be far better for Western Civilization
for Disney to become Disney again than
it would be for bent key to spend the
next 100 years becoming Disney yeah yeah
you know the the way I see it is
if I woke up tomorrow and Disney was
making good family-friendly content
crime was going way down the Democrats
apologize to Trump all of these things
turned around I I wouldn't know what to
even do I'd probably just sitting here
talking about UFOs or something and then
I'd go skateboarding and I'd be like I
don't need to do anything well those
those would be good shows too I would
just I would just sit at home with my
thousands and thousands and thousands of
unsold bottles of shampoo what you going
to do I would smell great and have
nothing to do I I feel feel like yeah I
you know the way way you describe it is
I'd probably much rather have one solved
these problems and then retire off into
the sunset and relax and hang out get
the get get a get a nice uh Brick Oven
gr some some burgers and hang out with
your friends and have a beer but instead
it's I wake up every day and I am deeply
concerned about what's going to happen
to this country should we decide to walk
away from the culture War can I take a
minute to talk about Mary Poppins my
favorite movie of all time and something
I wanted my children to see one of the
first movies they saw uh and and how
Disney now is the product or the victim
of rotten creativity they've killed
Ingenuity and I think of what Walt did
with with Mary Poppins and the way he
built the animatronic birds and all
these beautiful things and the the
meaning of that first movie uh the
original one is about a guy who loses
his job he's having a hard time at home
the the kids are missing his dad then he
got to bring the family together through
the beauty of imagination he and then
and then after all that he gets his job
back right in the new Mary Poppins that
they remade or it's like the second one
it was my first hint at Disney inverting
those uh those like meanings that are
deep important to me because I went to
go see it without my kids because I want
to check it out first I also love Mary
Poppins because it it's crazy he didn't
want to cry in front of them I I didn't
want to I cried cuz it was so bad
because they inverted the meaning in the
end in the end um the guy gets the
father gets his job back he's happy and
then finds uh value imagination with his
children that's totally different which
is completely opposite of how it should
be so that was for me when I first
started to realize this is just rotten
from the it is Disney okay so I someone
need I don't know if you guys can fact
check me and check this out real time
what uh the when was the sale of Marvel
to Disney not that long ago right right
it was was it a few years it was in 2009
2009 is when it happened yeah okay they
B they bought marel for 4 million four
billion billi yeah sorry so w then my
then my point was incorrect so I'll I'll
I'll set the one aside when I look at
don't let that stop you yeah well no no
I was going to make a point but I wanted
to make sure I was correct on my
timeline but I believe my timeline was
wrong my point I was going to make was
where where Disney is now with the
Marvel movies versus where they were
with the original Marvel movies right so
the the comparison I like to make often
is Captain America versus Captain Marvel
and why Captain Marvel bombs I mean the
first one I think did did decent and
then the last one was their worst ever
and why captain am helped create the MCU
and this big movie empire Captain
America is a scrawny weak man who
desperately wants to fight for his
country so much so that he's trying to
lie to trick his way into the army and
then they have that scene where it's a
Jack Nicholson's character oh no no it's
Tommy Lee not Jack nichon he's like I
want I don't want this scrawny guy I
want strong guys and he throws the fake
grenade and then it's the scrawny weak
Steve Rogers who jumps on the grenade to
save everybody else amazing scene what
is what is the ending of Captain Marvel
she was a woman who always had the power
but a man was keeping her down and kept
telling her to check her emotions it's
it's a caricature of what feminists
think being a woman is well that's what
happened in Snow White as well and you
had Rachel Zigler talking repeatedly
about how the new story was going to be
about how Snow White became a powerful
figure just like her father always
wanted and I remember she said that and
I was like oh we're going to cover this
for post millennial let me dig back and
see what happened that's not in the
Grims fairy tale it's not in the
original white Fair Brave and true I
think is what she said but she also was
talking about the father and doing all
this stuff and the father doesn't appear
anywhere um but the other thing too is
that basically what Disney did was give
Snow White the wicked Queen's plot the
wicked Queen is the one who goes after
power she's the one who is driven by
avarice and jealousy and they gave that
to Snow White they made two villains in
that story they obliterated the heroin
and they told little girls love and
kindness and caring for other people
that's not what you should strive after
what you should strive after is to be
you know a evil queen a girl boss
a girl boss boss and everybody knows
that after we see them all on Tik Tok
those girl bosses they're miserable also
Beauty let's don't leave out Beauty Snow
White is fundamentally about beauty and
one of the things that's challenging you
know one of the things Zigler said is
you know it's not 1939
anymore and it's true Snow White wasn't
written in 1939 it's an Ancient Ancient
fairy tale it was preserved by the
brothers Grim but it probably goes back
hundreds of years even before the Grim
writing and what is it about what is the
sort of Timeless truth that allowed that
story to be older than our country much
much older than our country and and I I
think that what the fairy tale is
actually about is something that we it's
so foreign to us because we live in a
world where we can't talk about reality
at all and we haven't been able to talk
about reality
forever but there is an in in the
original writing it's not even a
stepmother it's actually her mother oh
wow and even the Grim version changed
that between their original publication
and their later Publications because it
just felt too harsh but that is but the
the ancient fairy tale is the mother and
what the story is about is the very
common phenomenon that every parent
feels that over time your children
replace you and so the mother gained
notoriety or or attention or security
through her beauty and now her daughter
possesses more Beauty than she and you
know if you have a son you know I don't
but if you're the father of a son it's a
very common thing that people don't talk
much about when when your son brings
home the beautiful girl for prom when
he's 17 you know the father feels some
pride sure but he he also feels some
despair because it until now he's been
the one that women look to and now the
sun is and this is a it's a common
tragedy in life but it's but it's a
beautiful tragedy that over time our
children replace us and in our
generation where we live now now we
won't even have kids for fear of missing
out on any piece of Life the idea that
we could be replaced by our kids that
part of our job is to take all of our
not values although that too but our
value and impart that value into the
future by creating replacements for
ourselves that's what Snow White is
about I just got to say I don't have
kids but to anybody who has that
feeling when when when your son finally
beats you at basketball or football mhm
that should be one of the greatest
moments of your life absolutely that is
you winning that is you winning right
now and when you see your kids succeed
that is you succeeding you your whole
mission the other thing too that happens
when you have kids is at a certain point
in your life there's more life behind
you than there is ahead of you and you
can get lost in memories and looking
back but if you have a child then you
can see so far into the future it's
absolutely spectacular you can see you
can think about their future and their
children's future you know my son is
already tired of me saying don't forget
to give Mommy some grandbabies yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net